ragazzi miei prima di cominciare questo
video volevo dirvi che questo sarà
finalmente l'ultimo video di faul guys
di questa sera non è finita finalmente
la season di faul guys questo vuol dire
che da adesso in avanti ci saranno tutti
nuovi livelli e la season nuova inizierà
la prossima settimana ragazzi questo
video che state per vedere è stato uno
dei primi con registrato e ho voluto
metterlo come ultimo perché in realtà
non ho vinto ma vi voglio far vedere
quale è stata una delle sclerate più
pesanti da quando quando ho iniziato a
giocare a folgaria quindi prima di
diventare bravi luce dalla tiravo
pignata se non che adesso e non lo
faccia è però in questo episodio un po
particolare era uno dei primi voglio
concludere la season con una tastiera
rotta quindi buona visione e non mancate
alle prossime che sono già mossi bene
questa è una di quelle più odiate tra
tutti però l'ex con ancora non ho capito
la tattica giusta perché stavo andata
basta rimanere avanti però se come mese
in stronzo e parti in ultima fila parti
svantaggiati simo perché tutti quanti
sia il disastro un disastro totale cioè
non ci posso fare niente sono partiti
tutti la fila sono già svantaggiato io
cado per forza che cado sono partite in
ultima fila e sono tutti piegati quando
arrivo io cosa vuoi che faccia che poli
è proprio quello il fatto di stampa gli
stava secondo me non è meritocratico
perché se parti per ultimo si sta già da
prescindo a posto quali faida posto del
primo jean todt è già e già siamo
partiti male 43 reining si vola meglio
quanti ci hanno i premi perché ancora
nessuno cioè il problema è certo 10
corone google quando sono regista nostro
video dico 10 colonne chi c'è l'ha
subito così risparmiate coronerà che io
me ne terrei sempre 10 da parte perché
almeno non sapete mai che cosa compare
se compare una sim bella né novara
prende subito 10 coronano sempre da
parte ne ho quattro in totale hanno
guadagnate
tipo 10 quindi questo la potevo
prendermi la skin [ __ ] però non posso
ancora prendere uccello non ci ha
comprato un sacco di [ __ ] ma potevo
prendere quella leggendaria leggendaria
sono dieci corone per avere in totale
ragazzi e ne ho quattro quindi devo
mettere un bel po di vittorie da parte e
tenermele da parte le avrei deferito els
vendors ragazzi questa è una delle mie
preferite
se la gente non ti rotola addosso perché
questo è un grosso problema non mi farei
partire per ultimo anche stavolta
fai un po è un povero no sempre ultimo
grazie grazie che mi dico non bastare
paesi e sfonda no si sono prima vado a
culo gli oro
ho dato la testata giusta tra l'altro
provo a destra
niente la sinistra insomma libero per
ultimo è perfetto perfetto tutto a posto
ho dato una facciata una incornata
potentissima vabbè vago nas come secco
come seconda come mappa è maledetta e
perché vedete roero primo all'ultima
porta in un secondo stavo arrivando
ultima o friction adesso guarda un po
che non la faccio ragazzi e potrebbe
essere interessante perché se non la
faccia da un po potrebbe dare dei
risultati positivi ma ve l'ho detto come
minimo venga eliminata quanti promossi
qua 18 yes
stiamo sempre i lati solo perito primo
grazie non dovevate sempre i lati
ragazzi e vediamoli lofar gaga
telescopro già sono caduto e non so per
quale motivo ma si ma chi se ne frega
credo che la metà delle persone cada
random all'inizio c'è che inciampi non
ci sia uno script che ti fa inciampare
randon perché non vi spiego come mai
ogni tanto caso di tanto no senza un
valido motivo per fini stanno cadendo
davanti ok
perfetto legge o comunque vinto
nonostante la caduta iniziale questa
maledetta ravani dato inciampi
all'inizio senza un motivo
spero basta che non sia full monty ma
ovviamente ex ha con sé se ex traco
anche se perdo non me ne frega niente
perché se perde è colpa mia
va bene basta che non sia full monty mi
sono rotto le palle di fare col monte in
basta va bene hexagon sono contento così
23 questo dietro va bene ragazzi allora
facciamola bene vediamo di resistere e
non è facile ex a noi ragazzi però il
problema non è tanto più la mappa
difficile ma sono i player che trovi che
sono dei maledetti alcuni ok vediamo di
cadere qua perfetto buona la partenza è
buona e ragazzi
la partenza è ottima oserei dire oserei
dire ottima siamo in due
ora che pezzente o ok ok è qua e devo
andare dove è stato scremato di meno
no no va bene va bene va bene avere
provino proprio benissimo
va bene alle 90 problemi ok spremono
minimi il pad perfetto perfetto va
benissimo va benissimo
c'è tutta quella ancora non scoperta ai
ragazzi piano piano molto piano ci si
arriva molto piano ci si arriva devo
solo sfruttare al massimo tempo che o al
massimo perfetto perfetto perfetto qua
non lo so è perfetto gravissimo errore
bravo bravo bravo bravo così bravo così
è successo sono le mele non mancano le
mattonelle ma dove non era levato ma
scusami ma non stava gen non c'era né
matriciano più mattonelle
ma dove ma cosa c'erano ancora cinque
player c'erano cinque player attivi
quando c'ero io ma non dove stavano che
non c'era più niente
erano tutti erano era finito la mappa
era finita non mi è mai successo di
cadere non trovare mattonelle o meglio
se succede vinco perché non c'è niente
come cacchio stava la gente o c'era
tutta l'altra map o ho avuto una sfida
incredibile che tutta una parte di mappa
era tutta consumata e l'altra tutto a
posto
però mamma mi ha avuto una sfida
incredibile non lo so non ho capito come
ho perso però perso però sono contento
di come ho giocato quindi è molto strano
prove seconda manche hatemaj della
scuola allora qua i ragazzi io ho sempre
notato che in realtà se cadi non
cambiano anzi quasi quasi mi butto giù
di sotto apposta tanto non cambia nulla
cambia veramente poco passati sopra 18
uguale
quindi forse passo risolto perché di
sopra tanto passa troppa gente quindi
faccio prima a cadere e poi continuare
io 18 indirettamente aperto passo ci
siano problemi che ci sono non cambiava
niente raga tanto la velocità la stessa
vede l'agente di sotto è già avanti
cambia nulla qua ragazzi tutti si
buttano sempre nel centro ma non hai
capito che c'è anche il lato
effettivamente adesso non ci sono andato
perché potevano ovviamente al centro
malato non è da sottovalutare
adesso c'è quella rimasti in cassa
c'erano rimasti incastrati sì ma non ho
capito veramente come ha fatto a
rimanere col incastrato in mezzo alle
porte è stato trash allora credo di non
farcela e come prima ragazzi le facciate
sulla porta partiamo così che credo che
sia una partenza buona vediamo se buon
auspicio mettiamo la porta giusta
perfetto le uniche due porte che non si
sono aperte dove cade quindi questa
partita sarà meravigliosa al centro ok
tutto a posto
perché io valgo meno degli altri non al
centro la centro la nato a destra destra
ci si butta ma perché atto al palo
perfetto aspetta aspetta che sono pronto
a tirare un pugno di calcio a tazzina
fortissimo siamo grazie a lui
very nice ragazzi la mia tastiera si è
spezzata nice
non importa tanto giorgio istituto ho
rotto un po di cose ragazzi spero che
video sia piaciuto io comunque ci metto
la mia passione in ci vediamo
lasciatemi piace per adesso tutto bene
non vi preoccupate tanto stasera l'ha
già rottami di chi se ne frega e noi
come sempre ci vediamo al prossimo video
dai ragazzi
[Musica]